[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und ein
herzliches Willkommen Ihnen an meiner
Seite ist für den Sport Norbert Lehmann
schönen Abend der britische Premier muss
um seinen Job fürchten
es wird eng für Boris Johnson nach einer
Reihe von Skandalen wendet sich nun auch
seine eigene Partei von ihm ab
Energieversorgung in Deutschland die
Gasspeicher sind zu knapp zwei Dritteln
gefüllt die Bundesnetzagentur ruft zum
Sparen auf
und ab heute rollt der Ball mit der
Partie England gegen Österreich beginnt
in zwei Stunden die
Fußball-Europameisterschaft der Frauen
[Musik]
Boris Johnson steht am Abgrund so Titeln
britische Zeitungen heute der
Premierminister verliert in seiner
eigenen parteir rasant an Rückhalt aus
Protest gegen sein Verhalten traten
gestern Abend zwei seiner Minister
zurück heute folgten etliche weitere
getreue Johnson selbst will unbedingt im
Amt bleiben doch der Druck auf ihn
wächst stündlich aus London Yasin
herlein
Berufe für einen Premierminister bei
einer aktuellen Fragestunde im Parlament
das gibt es selten aber dies sind ja
auch keine gewöhnlichen Zeiten in der
Geschichte der britischen Demokratie
gibt es irgendwelche Umstände in denen
der Premierminister in Erwägung ziehen
würde zurück zu treten fragt ein
Abgeordneter aus Boris Johnsons eigener
Partei der Job eines Premierministers
unter schwierigen Umständen ist es immer
weiter zu machen und das gedenke ich
auch zu tun
Johnson ist immer noch ganz der Alte und
noch immer im Amt was erstaunt nach dem
Rücktritt seines Finanz und des
Gesundheitsministers gestern sowie
zahlreicher Staatssekretäre heute wird
die Luft für ihn und wirklich immer
dünner Grund für die neuerliche
Zuspitzung der Lage nach einer ganzen
Reihe von überstandenen Skandalen ist
die sogenannte pinscher-affäre dem
stellvertretenden Fraktionsführer Chris
Pinscher wird in mehreren Fällen
sexuelle Belästigung vorgeworfen für den
Entschluss Pinscher zu seinem Posten zu
verhelfen entschuldigte sich Johnson
gestern für etwas anderes allerdings
nicht nämlich dass Johnson seine
Kabinettskollegen mehrfach behaupten
ließ er habe von den Anschuldigungen
gegen Pinscher nichts gewusst was aber
nicht stimmt für die Opposition steht
fest Johnson der Regierungspartei haben
abgewirtschaftet
er ist nur deshalb noch an der Macht
weil er von einer korrupten Partei
gestützt wird die immer wieder das nicht
zurechtfertigende rechtfertigt
es hatte sich schon länger abgezeichnet
nun aber liegt endgültig der Falle
Geruch des Endes der Ära Johnson über
Westminster
bislang hat Boris Johnson noch jede
Krise überstanden Andreas Stamm wie ist
es diesmal
ja das Spiel ist aus die Ära Johnson
vorbei das ist der allgemeine Tenor es
gibt keinen politischen Beobachter der
glaubt dass Boris Johnson das überleben
kann und werden die Gesichter der
konservativen Abgeordneten heute hier
hinter mir im Parlament geschaut hat der
kann kaum zu einem anderen Schluss
kommen
Boris Johnson ist zurzeit in ten Downing
Street ist heißt es die engsten Getreuen
die letzten verbliebenen an seiner Seite
reden auf ihn ein bitte tritt zurück
erspartier und vor allen Dingen der
Partei weitere Charme und Schande die
Chancen dazu gegeben hat das
backblech-committee 9020 das sind die
mächtigen Hinterbänkler in seiner
Fraktion die wollten heute eigentlich
den Weg frei machen für einen
Misstrauensvotum dann hätte es heute
Abend oder spätestens morgen sozusagen
das Ende gegeben denn es sieht niemand
wie er das überstehen soll aber die
haben gesagt Vertrag auf Montag nimmt
diese Chance an tritt zurück oder Ende
eben wie ein Mini Trump so wurde er oft
geschalten der einfach nicht einsehen
kann dass seine Zeit abgelaufen ist dass
er raus ist aus dem Spiel und das andere
dann eben das weiterführen werden den
Königsmord denn wie gesagt in Boss in
London glaubt wirklich niemand mehr das
Boys Johnson eine Zukunft hat als
Premierminister über diese oder
vielleicht Anfang der nächsten Woche
hinaus Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung
aus London Andreas Stamm
nach Deutschland was tut die
Bundesregierung gegen die steigenden
Preise warum verlängert sie angesichts
der Energiekrise nicht die Laufzeiten
der Atomkraftwerke alles Fragen die
heute heftig im Bundestag diskutiert
wurden auf einige musste auch der
Bundeskanzler Antworten Patricia
Wiedemeier war dabei
egal ob Befragung des Kanzlers oder
aktuelle Stunde ist gegen um den
ukraine-krieg die Wirtschaftslage und
den drohenden gasmangel gleich zu Beginn
von Olaf Scholz ein klares Nein beim
Thema Atomkraft warum lassen sie die
drei Kernkraftwerke die noch am Netz
sind und grundlastfähig und sicher in
Deutschland laufen nicht befristet noch
weiterlaufen wie Sie sicher wissen geht
es ohnehin nur um Stromproduktion wenn
man die Atomkraftwerke betrachtet das
was wir an Heizenergie brauchen was wir
an Prozess Energie für die Unternehmen
brauchen das kann dadurch gar nicht
ersetzt werden in der Aktuellen Stunde
warf die Opposition der Regierung
Untätigkeit vor statt Reformen mache sie
nur eine konzertierte Aktion die dauern
Jahre sie sind endlose Gesprächsrunden
sie sind ein Alibi dafür dass sie keine
Reformen in diesem Lande durchsetzen
wollen wir brauchen dringend ein drittes
Entlastungspaket aber statt die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu schützen
schützen sie die Schuldenbremse von
Christian Lindner und das Ergebnis wird
jetzt ein lügenhaushalt sein Blinde und
plumpe Vorwürfe Rezepte aus der
Mottenkiste sein dass so die Antwort der
Ampelkoalition
mit überzeugt davon dass Olaf Scholz mit
der konzertierten Aktion gemeinsam mit
Gewerkschaft Unternehmen bis zum Herbst
die Maßnahme Pflegedienst aus der Krise
bringen selbstverständlich sind wir auf
der Welt unterwegs und gucken woher wir
Gas kriegen weil wir die Ver
antwortung dass wir Kohlekraftwerke ein
Stück länger laufen müssen wissen sie
weil wie das meiner Partei wehtut und
wir tun es weil es um Verantwortung geht
weil wir die im Unterschied zu ihnen
übernehmen der Kanzler hörte das alles
nicht mehr der Versuch der Opposition
ihn zurück ins Plenum zu zitieren
scheiterte
die Sorge ist groß dass im Winter das
Gas knapp wird darum soll jetzt gespart
werden um die Speicher zu füllen
über 40 unterirdische Gasspeicher gibt
es in Deutschland laut Bundesnetzagentur
sind sie im Schnitt zu knapp 63 Prozent
gefüllt der größte deutsche Speicher
befindet sich in Niedersachsen in Reden
aktuell ist er gerade mal zu einem
knappen viertel voll mehr von Peter Kunz
Klaus Müller ist der Mann der die
Gasspeicher bis zum Winter füllen soll
wird Deutschland das Gelingen der tun
auf jeden Fall alles dafür dass es
möglich wird seit seine Behörde den
Speicher in Treuhandschaft nahm ist der
Chef der Bundesnetzagentur zum ersten
Mal in Deutschlands größtem gasreservoir
nach langer russischer Blockade wird den
reden jetzt wieder mit maximal Last
eingespeichert aber wenn in kommenden
Tagen die Wartung der Nord Stream
Pipeline beginnt versiegt der
hauptgasstrom und danach so sind die
Signale aus Moskau und eindeutig von
beruhigenden Botschaften es geht wieder
zurück in ein Normalzustand bis zu
alarmierenden dramatischen Botschaften
es kann auch noch weniger werden ist
alles drin ich gehe davon aus dass diese
Unsicherheit gewollt ist es gibt
Russland alle Freiheitsgrade und wir
wissen schlicht nicht was in zwei Wochen
passieren wird speichern was geht aber
auch sparen was das Zeug hält das ist
der Appell des Obersten gasbeauftragten
der Bundesregierung entscheidend auch
die Festigkeit der europäischen
Solidarität können wir uns weiter auf
unsere Nachbarn wie Norwegen Belgien
Holland verlassen die gerade ganz
maßgeblich dazu beitragen unsere
Speicher zu befüllen der steil steigende
Gaspreis er hilft der Bundesnetzagentur
sogar beim Gasalarm Richtung kalter
Jahreszeit Industrie spart schon
womöglich weil es so viel kostet wenn
wir alle kurz treten so der Aufruf vor
der Kamera im Speicher reden dann kommen
wir auch warm durch den Wind
eine Reaktion zum Energiesparen erregt
gerade großes Aufsehen eine
Wohnungsgenossenschaft aus Sachsen
stellt ihren Mietern warmes Wasser nur
noch zu bestimmten Zeiten zur Verfügung
um Ihnen teure Nachzahlungen zu ersparen
wie es heißt die bundesbauministerin
hält das für rechtswidrig Franziska
Wunderlich hat Details
ein Aushang der viele Mieter kalt
erwischt hat denn ihr warmes Wasser wird
rationiert ich denke auch an die
arbeitende Bevölkerung die in Schichten
arbeiten die die vielleicht bald auch
immer baden oder durchmessen
betroffen sind 260 Wohnungen die mit Gas
beheizt werden und auch das Wasser mit
Gas erwärmt wird die
Wohnungsgenossenschaft entschied jetzt
die Heizung bleibt bis September kalt
warmes Wasser fließt nur noch früh
mittags und abends für wenige Stunden
wir erhoffen uns dort eine erhebliche
Einsparung für unsere Mitglieder in der
Abrechnung die ja nächstes Jahr es
kommen wird aber es gibt trotzdem dann
vielleicht Mitglieder die wird es geben
die echte Probleme haben die Nachzahlung
innerfrist von vier Wochen zu leisten
Nicole Geitner war anfangs nicht
begeistert sieht das nun aber anders in
unterhält sich aber in der Familie auch
darüber und begreift dann relativ
schnell auch mit dem Blick wie es jetzt
eben gerade in der Welt aussieht dass
[Musik]
das halt Mittelsinn um uns über diese
Krise zu bekommen es braucht Lösungen um
hohe Nachzahlungen abzufedern findet
auch der Dresdner Mieterverein aber
dafür brauche es das Einverständnis
jedes einzelnen Mieters wenn das mein
Vermieter einschränkt dann liegt Mangel
vor und dann habe ich entsprechende
Ansprüche dann kann ich den Anspruch
richtig durchsetzen und gegebenenfalls
kann ich sogar die Miete mindern in der
Fall in Dippoldiswalde hat die Debatte
wie die Energiekrise zu bewältigen ist
weiter angefacht
auch das EU-Parlament beschäftigte sich
heute mit Energie trotz massiver
Proteste von Klimaschützern stimmten die
Abgeordneten dafür Gas- und Atomkraft
unter bestimmten Bedingungen als
klimafreundlich einzustufen mit diesem
eu-siegel sollen Investitionen in diese
Energieformen attraktiver werden
Frankreich ist mit seinen 56
Atomkraftwerken die treibende Kraft
hinter den umstrittenen Plänen mit Hilfe
dieser Verordnung will die EU bis 2050
klimaneutral werden
das Öko Label der EU für Atom- und Gas
Österreich und Luxemburg wollen dagegen
klagen in der ZDF heute erfinden sie
auch eine Einschätzung unseres
Umweltexperten Christian deker
Russland setzt jetzt den
Rohstofflieferanten Kasachstan unter
Druck ein Gerichtsurteil hindert einen
Pipeline-Betreiber daran kasachisches Öl
durch Russland zu transportieren
begründet wurde die Entscheidung
offiziell mit Umweltbedenken Kasachstan
hatte der eu-angeboten mehr Öl und Gas
zu liefern das Land hat keinen eigenen
Zugang zu den Weltmeeren und ist deshalb
auf die Pipeline zum Schwarzen Meer
angewiesen
im Osten der Ukraine verschieben die
russischen Truppen die Front langsam
weiter nach Westen Kilometer um
Kilometer ihr nächstes Ziel ist die
Kontrolle über die gesamte Provinz
Donetzk mit massiven Bombardements auch
auf zivile Ziele bahnen sie sich den Weg
Thomas Gonsior berichtet
immer noch brennt es dort wo Geschosse
einschlugen dort wo Kleinhändler Fisch
Fleisch Gemüse verkauften
das war mein stand jetzt ist hier alles
zerstört der Marktplatz in slowensk
gestern Feuer nach dem Angriff pro
russischer Einheiten Zivilisten werden
getötet oder verletzt eine Attacke auf
wehrlose Tod und Leid zwischen
lebensmittelständen
mein Mann wollte sich noch in Sicherheit
bringen aber Splitter haben ihn schwer
verletzt
schon seit Tagen Angriffe auf Stadt und
Umland nach der Einnahme der Region
luhansk nimmt Russland nun jetzt ins
Visier slowianski und die
verwaltungshochburg krematorsk sie sind
nun Moskaus Hauptziele sagt der
ukrainische regional Gouverneur und ruft
zur Flucht auf aus ganz doniewski
1,6 Millionen Menschen lebten mal hier
jetzt sind es 350.000 ich mache mir
Sorgen um ihr Leben sie sollten gehen
bevor weiteres geschieht wie auch am
Sonntag als Raketen auf Vororte von
slofiansk niedergingen Daniel überlebte
seine Eltern nicht
meine Mutter noch als die Rettungskräfte
eintrafen war sie tot
der 22-Jährige muss sich nun um seine
kleine Schwester kümmern Daniels
Schicksal eins von so vielen in diesem
schier endlosen Krieg
dieser Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine
der Klimawandel und wirtschaftliche
Krisen all das hat den Hunger in der
Welt verschlimmert zu diesem Ergebnis
kommt der welternährungsberichte UNO bis
zu 828 Millionen Menschen haben nicht
genug zu essen das sind etwa 46
Millionen mehr als 2020 besonders
schlimm ist demnach die Lage in Afrika
und im Nahen Osten das größte Problem
sein die gestiegenen Lebensmittelpreise
so die UNO
hierzulande leben viele Ausländer in
einem bürokratischen nirgendwo mit
unklarem Status lediglich geduldet und
das seit Jahren ihnen will die Regierung
Entgegenkommen wer zum Stichtag
1.1.2022 fünf Jahre lang hier gelebt hat
und gut integriert ist soll ein
Aufenthaltsrecht bekommen erstmal für
ein Jahr mit der Perspektive auf ein
dauerhaftes Bleiberecht David Gebhard
berichtet
alire sei arbeitet bei der Post Sarah
Husseini will Zahntechnikerin werden
beide flüchteten 2016 aus Afghanistan
und im Iran ihr Asylantrag in
Deutschland wurde abgelehnt während sie
sich jahrelang von Duldung zu Duldung
hangelten machten sie Schulabschluss und
Berufsausbildung ich habe immer noch
Angst vor Abschiebung aber ich habe
gehört wenn man eine Ausbildung macht
und ein Abschluss in Deutschland hat
dann darf man in Deutschland bleiben
deswegen habe ich eine Ausbildung
angefangen nach Jahren des bangen könnte
ein neues ampelgesetz Rechtssicherheit
bringen und geduldeten eine Perspektive
wir wollen dass die Menschen die gut
integriert sind in Deutschland auch
echte Chancen haben wer seit fünf Jahren
geduldet in Deutschland lebt kann daher
ein einjähriges Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
erwerben das Innenministerium schätzt
dass so etwa 136.000 geduldete von der
Regel profitieren können ausgenommen
Straftäter und Gefährder ihre
Abschiebung soll erleichtert werden alle
anderen sollen in einer Art Probejahr
nachweisen dass sie die deutsche Sprache
ausreichend beherrschen für ihren
Lebensunterhalt selbst sorgen können und
ihre Identität nachweisen ist das
erfüllt wegent ein Bleiberecht
sie müssen ausreisen und gerade diesen
Menschen gibt man jetzt für ein Jahr
eine Chance das finden wir falsch
gleichzeitig wird die
abschiebungsoffensive überhaupt nicht
durchgeführt es wird eine kleine
Verschärfung vorgenommen die so merginal
ist dass sie gar nicht ins Gewicht fällt
Fachkräfte für den Arbeitsmarkt sollen
leichter kommen und ihre Familien
nachholen können andere nicht und so
sprechen flüchtlingsvertreter von einem
richtigen Schritt und sind dennoch
enttäuscht man schafft ein Gesetzentwurf
den man Chancen Bleiberecht nennt und
genau diese Chance nutzt man an dieser
Stelle nicht auch weitere Bereiche
umzusetzen um die Rechte von Familien
von Kindern tatsächlich vollumfänglich
zu erfüllen die Ampel hat umfassende
Reformen in der Migrationspolitik
versprochen weitere Pakete sollen folgen
Sarah und Ali hoffen dass ihr
Bleiberecht schon jetzt im ersten Paket
steckt
und jetzt zu Fuß frauenfußball-em in
England Norbert um 9 Uhr geht es los mit
dem Spiel der Gastgeberin gegen die
Österreicherinnen in Manchester vor
71.000 Zuschauer das ist
em-rekordkulisse ja und überhaupt soll
dieser Europameisterschaft im Mutterland
des Fußballs ein Turnier der Superlative
werden um den Frauenfußball noch
attraktiver zu machen
Abschlusstraining auf einem heiligen
Rasen Team England in Old Trafford die
Arena von Manchester United ein Name wie
ein Donnerhall und genau so wollen die
Titel Favoritin bei der Heim em
auftreten die Erwartungen riesig
wir sind keine Roboter wir werden nervös
sein wir spüren den Erwartungsdruck der
von außen kommt aber innerhalb der
Mannschaft geht es nur um Vorfreude
500.000 Eintrittskarten verkauft
em-rekord und Ausdruck der Begeisterung
fürs ganze Turnier der Siegerpokal schon
eingetroffen den die englischen Fans
nicht mehr hergeben wollen
zum Auftakt gegen Österreich und dann
weiter bis ins Finale in Wembley ich bin
so aufgeregt bin ein so großer
england-fan
der vielleicht größte Trumpf mit Sarina
Wiegmann haben die englischen Löwin eine
Trainerin die mit Druck umgehen kann als
Coach hat sie 2017 die Niederländerinnen
zum Titel geführt bei deren Heim
jetzt ist der Wechsel perfekt Borussia
Dortmund meldet die Verpflichtung von
Sebastian orlea der 28-Jährige
Mittelstürmer von Ajax Amsterdam und
Ex-Frankfurter hält einen
4-jahresvertrag Ablöse Summe angeblich
31 Millionen Euro 5 etappe der Tour de
France streckenweise über
Kopfsteinpflaster viele Stürze und am
Ende ein Foto Finish Sieg des
australischen Radprofis Simon Clark aus
der Ausreißergruppe heraus konnte Simon
Clark sein Rad knapp vor das des
Niederländers Takko van der Horn
schieben nach einem extremen Rennen mit
hohem Tempo und Risiko von Lille durch
das berüchtigte Rebell nach Arenberg
auch Vorjahressieger tadell pogatschow
fuhr schon im Angriffsmodus 40 km/h über
höllisches Kopfsteinpflaster und hat
seine Favoritenrolle unterstrichen doch
in gelb bleibt Belgier food fun Art Team
Jumbo Wismar bester Deutscher wurde als
Zwölfter Maximilian Wahlscheid
und morgen die längste Etappe 220 km mit
Abstecher nach Belgien in Richtung
Vogesen und wir haben zum Schluss noch
eine kleine Anregung für Sie zur
weiteren Abendgestaltung denn heute ist
internationaler Tag des Kusses die
Deutschen sind eher zurückhaltend nur
vier Schmatzer gibt es im Schnitt am Tag
dabei macht küssen glücklich ist gesund
und Kalorien verbrennt man auch noch was
einen guten Kuss ausmacht wenn es wie
bei diesen beiden hier auch nach 50
Jahren noch prickelt
[Gelächter]
unbezahlbar fehlt noch das Lotto die
Gewinnzahlen lauten 1 26 38 41 47 48 und
die Superzahl 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
in der Nacht zieht Regen auf die Details
zum Wetter hat gleich erst den terli
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie im
heutigen Journal um viertel vor zehn und
hier übernimmt morgen nitri Sirin alles
Gute ihnen und auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter Regen ist Segen
muss man ja in diesen trockenen Tagen
sagen und Regen kommt auf durchaus 20
Liter auf den Quadratmeter mit dieser
Kaltfront in der kommenden Nacht und bis
zu 20 Liter auf den Quadratmeter auch
morgen tagsüber in der Nacht also schon
mal Schauer und Gewitter die allmählich
sich weiter Richtung Mitte bewegen
ansonsten im Süden weiterhin trockenes
Wetter bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 7
Grad am Alpenrand und 16 Grad ganz im
Westen ja und morgen am Vormittag ziehen
diese Schauer und Gewitter weiter
teilweise über den Main weiter südwärts
ansonsten ganz im Süden noch trocken zum
Nachmittag rutscht das ganze aber weiter
in den Süden und sie sehen ja auch
Gewitter sind dabei nur Richtung
Oberrhein bleibt es erstmal trocken die
Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte im
Südwesten bei 25 Grad 17 Grad dann
Richtung Rockland häufig Werte um die 20
Grad Marke teilweise auch darunter die
kommenden Tage am Freitag größtenteils
trocken nur im südenschauer bis 26 Grad
Samstag etwas wärmer bis 28 Grad im
Nordosten Regen ein schöner Abend